alors nous voilà dans cette première
orangerie en france 7 orangerie de dons
paciello de marco llano où ils arrivent
avec des plantes bigaradier et des
orangers amer on en a aujourd'hui plus
de 200 et c'est la spécificité de ce
nouveau venu dans la cour des grands
châteaux de la loire château gaillard ne
date pourtant pas d'hier
il a été construit en 14 196 sur
commande du roi charles ii 8 qui veut à
quelques pas du château royal d'amboise
un logis à l'italienne témoin de
l'architecturé de la première partie de
la renaissance pour parfaire ce bijou
d'élégance charles witt confie la
réalisation des jardins à un moine
paysagiste donne pas de celle de marco
llado l'homme qui plante ici les tout
premiers orange et de france
il était le plus célèbre jardinier de
son temps les premiers orange est arrivé
en france les caisses d'empotage naples
et les caisses orangé l'acériculture
tous cette naissance du paysagisme et
dans un écrin intact avec un château
qu'on peut qualifier de palazzo taux de
petit palais italiens entièrement
sculptée intacte et des collections qui
à l'intérieur du château ont été
reconstitués depuis cinq ans et qui
montre des choses rares des choses
originales et des choses qu'on voit par
ailleurs et il faut au moins cela pour
exister aujourd'hui à côté de chambord
chenonceau et bien d'autres dans une
économie touristique concurrentiel mais
florissante château gaillard est ouvert
au public après cinq années de travaux
est désormais l'un des rares monuments
privé visitable toute l'année ils se
transforment au gré des saisons et se
met pour la première fois de sa nouvelle
histoire aux couleurs de noël
devant le succès d'amitié d'émotion d'un
visiteur on a décidé de faire de vrais
choix derrière toute l'année et de faire
ce premier noël alors c'est un saut de
l'ange sans faire le moindre jeu de mots
parce que il faut inventer évidemment
quelque chose qui soit complètement
nouveau a lancé le noël
au royaume des orangers
un hommage au créateur des jardins du
château gaillard est un vrai enjeu
économique
le site est maintenant une pme employant
9 salariés et accueillant déjà cinquante
mille visiteurs par an
[Musique]